[Music]
I I have so many things I want to talk
about with this movie but I'd love to
talk about the fact that it originated
from a book by peral Everett called
eraser yes and I'm so curious to just
hear about for you as someone that we
know as a writer um what was the process
of
coming to the book choosing the book
adapting the book and and making that
transition to film yeah you
know I found the novel in December of
2020 I was reading a review for a
different book called interior Chinatown
and in that review it said that uh
interior Chinatown had a satire
reminiscent of persal ever AER I'd never
read a erer so went out and bought it
and kind of immediately
uh felt like it you know have you ever
read a book that felt like it was
written specifically for you that's how
that's how it felt when I was reading
this novel it was not just the kind of
you guys have seen the movie so I can't
spoil it not just like the
satirical themes about what it means to
be a creative of color and and the
expectations that put people put on you
because of that but also you know I have
two older siblings we have a weird sort
of like sibling Trio Dynamic sometimes
we're closer at some points and we're
more distant in other points we we all
have a very sort of overbearing Father
Figure in Our Lives who looms pretty
large and I'm sure he will when he's
gone uh my mother didn't die of
Alzheimer's but my mother died of cancer
eight years ago and so there was a
period of time when like Lisa my oldest
brother was living in our hometown and
taking care of her and then toward the
end of her life I came home and sort of
took care of her for for sort of like
the the last days of her life so there
was all these just strange overlaps in
the novel that's it started to feel
eerie and so I just felt like oh I know
this I really know this story in my
bones and so about 50 pages in I knew
that I wanted to adapt it about 100
pages in I started reading the novel and
Jeffrey wri's voice that's how early I
started thinking of Jeffrey as sort of
like I started envisioning him in the
scenes um yeah and so as soon as I was
done with it I I reached out to my
manager and asked if we could get in
contact with peral and and percel asked
to speak to me on the phone and when we
talked for about a half an hour he asked
me why why I was interested I told him
why I was passionate about it and then
he gave me
he gave me the rights for free for 6
months he said he said go off and he
said go write a script and if if
anything comes of it then then you can
pay me then and so uh I will I'm forever
grateful to him for that because he you
know rights discussions can get tied up
in legal stuff for months if not years
so he just said go ahead and feel free
and I I I was uh yeah I'll be forever
indebted to him for that I'm I'd love to
ask you something that I loved about the
movie was its example examination of our
cultural resistance to
complexity combined with the film's
actually very complex relationship to
the the novel my pathology and then
retitled um because I get the sense
that you as the
filmmaker were not willing to completely
write it off and in fact found some room
to embrace something of it in that it
exists yeah and so I'd be curious to
know how
you tonally approached that in making
the film and and working with
Jeffrey you know in terms of
finding Mercy for the character oh yeah
and also a sense of letting go of Shame
yeah so Mercy for the character of Monk
you're saying yeah yeah that he finds
for himself yeah yeah I think that I
think that one of the things that
Jeffrey does beautifully in the film is
that it's hard to play a lovable Grump
right like sort of if you air to if to
if you air too far on the side of grump
then you sort of lose everybody and
nobody's rooting for you anymore and so
one of the things that Jeffrey does and
just came into the part playing
naturally um was there's I'm going to
talk to you guys about my therapist I'm
sorry this is going to be a very La Q&A
um
I had a therapist once who told me this
really great thing that I think of a lot
which is she said that uh she because I
used to have anger issues and she said I
still have anger issues but I've learned
to channel that anger in a much
healthier way but she
said uh anger is not a real emotion she
just said it's anger is a secondary
emotion and underneath anger especially
for men is either pain or fear and that
sort of we have been socialized in in a
society that sort of like doesn't really
take kindly to men saying like I feel
afraid or you hurt my feelings and that
those kinds of things used to be very
hard for me to say um and so instead you
know I would get mad because that was
sort of like the way that men dealt with
things and I think that the thing that
Jeffrey does really well in the
character here and why why you root for
him despite the fact that he's so
pugnacious like he's fighting from the
start of the movie he's fighting with
his students and his colleagues and his
family and his girlfriend like he's just
fighting with everybody but I think that
sort of like what wins you over is that
he plays it in such a way that
despite the fact that you could see him
fighting all the time you can see that
he's in a lot of pain you sort of like
see that he's hurting that's sort of
like this isn't a guy who's just rude to
be rude he's sort of just so frustrated
and he's hurt and he's hurt that his
father killed himself he's hurt that uh
his mother is he's losing his mother
he's hurt that his sister's died he's
hurt that he's alienated from his
brother he's hurt that his work isn't as
as popular as he thinks it should be
like there's all these things that that
are that he's frustrated and hurt by and
you can really see that in just the
character that that that he in the way
that he sort of decided to play the
character at the outset and so I think
that you know Finding Mercy for for that
character was something that we you know
Jeffrey and I always were in lock Step
At the beginning that we wanted it to be
um we wanted it to
feel uh we wanted it to
feel how am I going to put this Jeffrey
and I always wanted it the movie to make
a movie that we were we were making a
movie that I think allowed the
characters to be messy because I think
that that's something that black actors
don't often get to get to play is messy
characters um it's either sort of you
know one or the other it's either sort
of like a crackhead or the president of
the United States you know it's sort of
like it is like the that is frequently
like the two polls that that black
actors are allowed to play and so we
wanted to play somebody that just felt
real in this way and that felt messy and
that but was complex and nuanced and and
we we wanted that for all the characters
really we wanted that for Sterling we
wanted that for for Coraline for Agnes
like for everybody in the in the film we
wanted them to to have that um grace and
mercy I guess you could call it we we
sort of wanted to make it feel like real
people and and and real people are
deeply flawed but the but most of them
you know most of them are are are trying
their best at the end of the day yes and
and the pleasure of the movie is for me
anyway is in
seeing a sense of Unfinished selves you
know that that every
character is to some degree wrestling
with new things and changing and
evolving and rejecting and embracing
things but that there's this larger
cultural imperative to be one thing to
say one thing and of course that's not
really what art or culture is is and so
I was really moved by the depiction of
so many different kinds of struggles
with that sort of um limiting
essentialism thanks yeah I think
that I don't something that I never
wanted the sort of the movie to suggest
was that that we you know black art
needs to be cheery and it all needs to
be comedies and why are we talking about
uh uh why are we so so depressing all
the time and it's it's like look I'm not
saying that we should do that I'm saying
that like you know sometimes your
father's not a dead be dad he's just uh
he's emotionally unavailable like that's
that that is something black people deal
with as well it's not just like your
dad's in jail or he's been killed or or
he's run off or something else it's like
sometimes he's there and present and
like successful and he's a doctor and
he's smart but he's also just deeply
unot emotionally unavailable and so that
that kind of like screws with your
relationship with him uh you know
there's a whole
look yes the black experience includes
slavery it absolutely does but it also
as I said includes the president of the
United States and there's a sort of like
whole world of stories in between those
two polls that we very rarely get to see
you know it is it is uh it is strange to
me that sort of despite that variety of
life we really only get the same five or
six rehash stories about the black
experience over and over over and over
and so it was important to me to depict
that that sort of like it was important
to me to depict that variety even within
the same family right like even within
the same family people who are raised
under the same roof are vastly different
and sort of and and and I wanted to
express that and show the sort of you
know I think that Blackness you know and
this isn't something that just is about
yes this is about a black man and his
family but I have Mexican friends who
say why does every movie or TV show shot
in Mexico have to be drug cartels or or
you know somebody escaping their
miserable small village for sort of like
the promised land that he's the United
States of America and why does it always
have to have that weird burnt sienna
sheen on the on the over the over the
lens every time they're shooting in
Latin America right like there there is
there is this sort of strange reluctance
to acknowledge the sort of like depth
and breadth of other people's lives um
in this industry and so yeah it was
important to me to just and it's
important to me in everything that I
that I do to just sort of acknowledge
like we're not a monolith we're very
different people and I'm going to sort
of despite the fact that people keep
trying to put us in this box I just feel
like we we just have to keep letting
them know that we're trying to break out
of it as much as possible yes yes um I'm
sorry I'm just realizing how much I've
I've turned into Jeffrey right this is
this is actually I just I haven't I
haven't worn this suit
since since we made this post
and I'm just realizing that I'm doing
Jeffrey right I'm doing monk cosplay and
it's uh really I feel deeply
embarrassed down to the glasses man wow
wow I I guess the cosplay is kind of
unconscious at this point truly but I
that's part of the art of the movie I
think um I mean I was also thinking for
myself as a filmmaker
how how you know
frequently we as artists and and people
who work in film are sort of asked to do
our our important work and then
our our genre slumming it right and that
for me I'm I'm
increasingly sort of um wanting to just
embrace the idea that
there's value to all kinds of work all
kinds of genre and um I want to say sort
of archetypal expressions and so I was
really I was also really heartened to
see that there was a lack of judgment
you saw that that that monk judged
himself but that in fact the world
around him didn't judge him nearly as
intensely as he judged himself which I
think is such an interesting
character to give an audience yeah
that so that so that scene with Monk and
Centura at the end of toward the end of
the film so complex and interesting
thanks yeah so so that when I was
reading the novel I was very excited for
the moment when Monk and Sara were going
to come face to face and we would get to
read their ideological differences and
it never came that scene's not in the
book and so when I when I sat down to
write the script I knew that I wanted to
include that because I didn't I didn't
want to make make a movie in which
Centura was the villain something that I
said sort of sat down to
say when Jeffrey and I first started
talking about the script the thing that
we both agreed on was we didn't want to
police Blackness and we didn't want to
police art and we especially didn't want
to police black art and so and and it to
me it sort of in keeping with the novel
The the epilogue of of um of uh eraser
uh is this is this uh Latin phrase that
I was unfamiliar with and and apparently
it's used in relationship with complex
mathematics and the and the rough transl
the rough translation is I offer no
hypothesis and so it's sort of like to
me what that suggested was if I want if
I was trying to keep the spirit of the
book alive I couldn't make something
didactic I couldn't make something that
was like here's the moral lesson that
you should learn on your way out the
door I didn't want to do that I just
wanted to put forward a series of
characters and scenarios and situations
and then let people decide for
themselves what what they what they
thought of it and so that scene to me
was a Lynch pin of of of of the film to
do that was to was to never make Centura
a villain and sort of to to kind of
surprise the audience the way that the
way that monk himself is surprised when
he's like oh you're formidable and
thoughtful and you've considered these
things and I sort of I just thought that
you were kind of um a dilatant who just
wanted to sort of like come in and and
make a bunch of money real quick and and
didn't actually care and to
me the thing that I had a real growth
moment in in my life is an artist when
because I used to be very much like monk
in the way that I was like well why are
you making this kind of work and this
kind of work is bad and you should you
should feel bad for making this and
aren't you embarrassed and and sort of
it was a real growth moment for me when
I realized one day that that question
like why are you making the art that you
make I think the art is bad is the is
the wrong question sort of like the more
interesting and valid and important
question is cu the reality is is that
Centura is making her work within a
system and with and within an
institution that has sort of like
existed long before she was ever around
right and so she is making work within a
set of parameters that people have built
and constructed around artists right and
so she's just making her work the way
that she wants to make her work the same
way that monk is making the work that he
wants to make and so I think that the
the question is less about like why is
why is Sara making that art the more the
more important question is why are the
people 15 levels above and monk who who
hold the purse strings who Greenlight
movies and TV shows and novels why are
they so interested in telling the same
few stories over and over and over about
about these groups of people why is
there such a Poverty of imagination when
it comes to what our lives look like
right that to me is a far more important
question than why is this person making
the art that they make far be it for me
to sort of art is hard it's a difficult
it's a difficult path to sort of make a
life as a creative and so if you got to
make what you got to make to put food on
your table and keep a roof over your
head and sort of stay an artist then far
be it for me to criticize that I'm more
interested now in like why the people up
here are so limited in their perspective
of what our lives look like that to me
is more
important this is your debut film MH and
I would love to hear from you
um about the process of making the film
and conceiving it and prepping it what
if anything were the things that
surprised you the most about that
process and and getting a film from
start to
finish um I think I was surprised by how
much I really really enjoyed it that was
that that that was the thing I'd been
working I'd been a TV writer for about
um seven or eight years before we
started shooting this and I really love
my TV work and I and I really am proud
of it and and and learned a lot there
but TV writing at the end of the day for
me a lot of the time was you know you
drive to the lot and you get your salad
from Jones on Third and you and you Rite
a little bit and then you go home at 600
p.m. and it's like it was it was great
but I felt really I I don't think that I
realized how much I felt removed from
the final product and felt removed from
sort of like what was going on outside
of that our sort of like fium there and
so
uh just from the moment we were sort of
like in the production offices for
pre-production and then sort of like
being on set every day like just being
in the thick of it the thing that I
realized was that I just missed this
it's not as if you don't do this in
writer room but it's just like it's just
creative problem solving with sort of
like people that you like around you and
that's all it was and it was like and I
realized like oh being like with 80
people at 1:00 a.m. in the Rain On A
Tuesday and sort of like you're all
hungry and tired and and you know you
want to go home but you're you're there
building this thing together like the
camaraderie of that and sort of like the
the the um yeah just the just the way
that you sort of like make fast friends
with people like I'm I worked with some
of those people on you know we had 26
day shoot I worked with some of those
people for like around a month and I
am like they're they're going to be
friends of mine forever and I've worked
on TV shows for years years and it's
like yeah I like those people I love
them and they're going to be my friends
but you know just the sort of the
relationships that I built with those
people over that short amount of time uh
it was wonderful just because what
you're doing is is just you're there to
achieve the same thing every day and
you're in the same struggle and I loved
that and so I think that I didn't
realize like how I love my TV jobs but
they've I don't think that I sort of
realized how much I just really wanted
to be in the thick of it and getting my
hands dirty like that well and the
pleasure of being being the final
decision yeah you know it must have felt
just wonderful yeah but also the
pleasure of like surrounding myself the
the thing that I told everybody who from
Jeffrey Wright on down the thing that I
told everybody was listen I uh I've
never done this before I've never
directed traffic it doesn't like this is
all brand new to me I've I'd never
written a movie before this and so the
the thing that I said was like I
understand it's hard to be a
cinematographer that's a hard job it's
especially a hard job on a independent
movie with limited resources and limited
money so if you don't want to do your
job and teach me sometimes I totally
understand that I don't begrudge you
that like it's hard to be a
cinematographer and if you don't want to
be a cinematographer and a substitute
teacher sometimes that's okay that's
reasonable it's a reasonable thing to
say to say no and walk away from that um
because I'm not going to understand
everything at the outset I'm I'm smart
and I'm a quick learner but there's
going to be things that that you need to
help me understand and I told everybody
that so everybody who signed on to the
movie um I just felt incredibly you know
I hope that they felt protected with me
and sort of like protected with with the
movie that I made and I hope they feel
proud of it but even more so I felt
protected by all of them you know so
that's sort of what allowed me the
courage to go to work every day and sort
of like and and and wake up and get out
of bed and so that I wasn't sort of
trembling in fear every day was that I
had these people around me who so not
just sort of so I could make the final
decision but I'd hired people who I
really trusted to help me make the final
decision if that makes sense like that
was that sort of meant the world to me
was I I hired when I hired my editor
Hilda I told her I was like just don't
ever lie to me you know that's all that
I care about is don't is is if you think
something's bad tell me it's you think
it's bad and she did and sometimes it
pissed me off but but it was great
because after a few minutes I I was like
oh no this is why I hired you is I hired
you to be honest with me and to help me
make this thing better and so I just
felt I don't believe in the aour thing I
wrote it and directed it of course but
uh there was hundreds of people who who
helped me achieve this vision and um I
just felt so supported by all of them
which made my job much
easier well the collaboration you're
talking about I think
only enhanced the complexity of the film
The complexity that you're encouraging
and interrogating in the film and it
really shows and um I've just been told
we're out of time and um there's so much
more to talk about but I just want to
say thank you so much for making this
thank you thank you all so
[Music]
much